tout dans le monde c'est le cyber
harcèlement cette haine qui s'exprime
sur les réseaux sociaux et qui peut tous
nous toucher pour peu que l'on ait un
avis qui ne plaisent pas à tout le monde
la jeune milla en a fait les frais après
avoir posté une vidéo il faut le dire
très insultante sur l'islam
aujourd'hui treize de ses harceleurs ont
commencé à être jugés solène boisé déjà
aux portes de l'audience le débat fait
rage
on doit ces machines pour nous on ne
sait pas vous êtes athée c'est bien mais
faut pas insulter une ombre au discuter
car les propos tenus par la jeune milla
qui a vivement critiqué l'islam sur son
compte tik tok en novembre dernier ont
choqué en quelques mois la jeune fille a
reçu des centaines de milliers de
messages de haine jusqu à des appels au
meurtre
treize prévenus âgés de 18 à 30 ans
comparaissent au tribunal correctionnel
pour harcèlement et menaces de mort
l'avocat de millas revendique son droit
au blasphème imaginer sa vie elle ne
peut plus aller en terrasse
tranquillement elle peut plus se balader
dans la rue elle peut plus avoir le
stage elle paye à elles toutes les
portes puisse enfermer
c'est insupportable et je ne remets pas
enfin que les treize personnes qui sont
là aujourd'hui soit tous passés par
notre système éducatif et qu'aucune ne
sache que la critique des religions
c'est légal et ça n'a rien à voir avec
du racisme
plusieurs demandes de renvois ont été
formulées par certains avocats de la
défense
il dénonce une procédure
disproportionnée destiné selon eux à
mettre un coup de projecteur sur le
cyberharcèlement un crime reconnu depuis
seulement trois ans on n'était pas
obligé de le placer en garde en garde à
vue qu'on n'était pas non plus obligé de
le renvoyer devant un tribunal
correctionnel
la procédure pénale offre plein d'autres
possibilités surtout s'agissant d'un
jeune adulte qui n'est pas connu des
services surtout s'agissant de preuve
qu'ils étaient figées et donc y avait
pas de problème de dépérissement preuve
est en réalité ça montre quoi ça montre
peut-être qu'on avait envie de mettre la
lumière sur une nouvelle infraction
une nouvelle audience pour statuer sur
le fond de la sphère est fixée au 21 et
22 juin prochain
les treize prévenus risquent de à
trois ans d'emprisonnement et jusqu'à
45000 euros d'amendé pour harcèlement en
ligne et menaces de mort est avec nous
pour le grand débat ce soir à giuseppe
de martino bienvenue à vous vous êtes co
fondateur du média en ligne
l'outsider président de l'association
des services internet communautaires
pour un internet ouvert et responsable
c'est le slogan serge abiteboul
bienvenue à vous également vous êtes
directeur de recherche pour l'institut
national de recherche en informatique et
en automatique membre de l'académie des
sciences est membre du collège de
l'arcep alors genre disque et l'arcep
autorité de régulation des
communications électroniques des poste
et de la distribution de la presse
avec nous également à distance s'ils
arrivent à la bienvenue vous êtes avocat
au barreau de paris spécialiste en droit
des médias de l'internet et du numérique
et lætitia via et également avec nous
bien venu êtes député en marche de
pompiers membres de la commission des
lois vous êtes à l'origine d'une
proposition loi
ils ont à lutter contre la haine en
ligne laetitia via une grande partie de
ce texte a été censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel alors on ne va pas
refaire l'histoire mais quand même
est ce que vous vous dites au fond de
vous que votre loi aurait pu empêcher ce
qui est arrivé à milla aurait pu
permettre de mieux juger ses agresseurs
une chose qui est certaine c'est qu'à
l'époque où on a défendu la proposition
brion public était peut-être pas
suffisamment sensibilisés à la question
de l' ennemi je vois aujourd'hui que le
sujet fait consensus
je comprends que il ya une vraie volonté
de justice en la matière est une
véritable volonté de régulation
ensuite en ce qui concerne les
dispositions qui permettent de
poursuivre ces personnes elles résultent
de loi qui existait déjà une fois qu'on
a voté sous cette mandature
dans le cadre de la loi sia par don qui
permet de lutter contre les règnes
mairie le cyber harcèlement et y est
aussi un autre élément qui relève de ma
proposition de loi le parquet numérique
qui a permis de mieux appréhender les
auteurs de ces contenus et de ce cyber
harcèlement de pouvoir les poursuivre et
donc de pouvoir les déférer devant cuche
viendra évidemment à ce parc est
numérique vous aérer
giuseppe de martino c'est intéressant
est ce que finalement aujourd'hui une
loi avia pardon c'est votre nom laëtitia
mais cette loi passerait davantage
auprès de l'opinion et peut-être
davantage auprès du conseil
constitutionnel ou pas pardon d'être si
direct que madame la députée mais il y
avait un problème de fond sur ce sur
cette proposition de loi
demandez aux plateformes de prendre ce
rôle de juge de décider à la place du
juge de dire le droit semblait
totalement peu praticable et a été à
notre sens justement censurée par le
conseil constitutionnel par contre je
rejoins complètement madame avia sur le
fait qu'il est nécessaire de rechercher
les auteurs de deux de ces comportements
haineux illicites quels qu'ils soient et
de donner plus de moyens à la fois aux
autorités répressives mais également aux
autorités judiciaires former sans doute
mieux les juges donner plus de moyens et
permettre une fluidité dans la prise de
décision de justice qui donneront
l'exemple et qui enfin permettront de
croire qu'il n'y a pas d'impunité sur
internet parce que c'est quand même ça
le problème serge abiteboul on a
l'impression qu'on est quand même un peu
impuissant face à ces cyber arcelor qui
donne des affaires comme celle autour de
la jeune mais là c'est clair et c'est
clair qu'il ya une prise de conscience
comme le sud le souligner madame avia si
une prise de conscience de la société
qu'on peut pas continuer comme ça mais
en même temps il ya aussi une
il faut il faut tenir compte du fait que
ces outils sont des outils de liberté
d'expression ces outils sont importants
et pour beaucoup de gens on représente
la façon de s'exprimer la façon de
parler donc il faut arriver
collectivement à trouver des solutions
qui permettent de fixer le problème qui
permet de s'appuyer aussi sur les sur
les grandes entreprises qui ne veulent
pas fondamentalement ferme à la veulent
bien participer et ce qui est peut-être
le plus compliquée et plus difficile à
atteindre c'est faire que pour répondre
à ce que disait monsieur de martino que
ce soit la société qui s'empare de sa
que ce soit pas juste aux réseaux
sociaux de décider ce qu'on a le droit
de dire qu'on n'a pas le droit de dire
et de définir notre société d'une
certaine façon à ce qu'il dit là dessus
ça définit ce que nous sommes donc c'est
aussi à nous de nous réapproprier d'une
certaine façon notre parole tout en
luttant contre contre la haine learning
est hélas je partage complètement le les
buts de madama bien mais on voit bien
que c'est compliqué quand même ses
rivales a le droit à la liberté
d'expression c'est ce que d'ailleurs on
a un droit qui est adapté ou pas
aujourd'hui pour moi le droit est tout à
fait adapté on a aujourd'hui tous les
outils réglementaires et législatifs
pour pouvoir sanctionner ce type de
comportement en ligne
alors le délit de cyber-harcèlement
existe en réalité depuis 2014
il a été complété heureusement
d'ailleurs par la loi la loi schiappa de
2000 2018
avec donc le harcèlement de me tall et
les raids les rênes numérique et avec
cette ce pan de la loi la loi de madame
avia sur la création du parc national
numérique avec la création depuis
quelques quelques mois donc de ce pôle
numérique donkey de lutte contre la
lettre elle a aidé en ligne qui a
commencé ses activités qui a commencé
d'ailleurs par ses investigations à voir
la semaine dernière une des décisions
ont été rendues dans le cadre de cyber
harcèlement
donc on a aujourd'hui tous les outils
pour pouvoir distinguer ce qui est de la
liberté d'expression et ce qui est dû
d'une expression numérique complètement
dénaturé avec des héros tweet de
simplement de bêtes et méchants et qui
font tellement mal à la victime qui en
recevant des dizaines
de milliers de messages et aujourd'hui
voilà complètement détruites et sa vie
sa vie également donc il ya un aspect
pédagogique très très important qui va
falloir développer au delà de l'aspect
répressif et juridiques de bien faire
comprendre aux gens que l'internet c'est
par les maisons de l'endroit que
internet est effectivement on peut pas
faire n'importe quoi que derrière
planqué derrière son écran
c'est pas comme dans la rue ils essaient
d'ailleurs on les retrouve au tribunal
cesser ces gens ils ne vont pas de se
balader dans la rue en dix ans la toile
et en proférant des injures contre les
quidams qui passe il le fond derrière
leur ordinateur pourquoi parce qu'il
pense que il ya une espèce d'impunité
derrière un pseudonyme
on est confortablement installé ce n'est
pas vrai il n'y a pas d'abus cette
impunité pardonnez moi mais de fait elle
est un peu l'art est d'ailleurs dans la
ferme et la sarre soleure il ya eu des
milliers de messages y en a 13 qui sont
devant les tribunaux c'est vrai alors ça
fait ça fait peu par rapport au
potentiel au potentiel
après il faut voir si tout le monde
était était répréhensible
il faut voir ceux qui ont tué près il
faut bien voir que quand on dépose une
plainte
c'est déjà bien d'avoir 13 dans un
premier temps parce que l'enquêté
toujours en cours
c'est toujours pas fini le lh le dos et
si le l'office numérique continue son
sans son oeuvre
peut-être d'autres auront également à
passer par les fourches de la delà de
l'aide de la justice de la 10e chambre
correctionnelle
donc c'est pas fini c'est déjà pas mal
13 il faut pas non plus penser que
pratiquement on va leur faire un procès
avec dix mille personnes
c'est rigoureusement impossible en
revanche ce qu'il faudra au niveau des
delà du suivi du procès et des peines
qu'elle soit je ne suis pas pour le tout
répressif il pour le tout dissuasif mais
qu'elles soient compréhensibles
ok on ne puisse pas dire bah oui
j'associe c'est que ça concourt his ass
rsa on peut y aller être dissuasif
laetitia via c'est peut-être une des
clés donc oui je pense que la lutte
contre la haine en ligne elle repose sur
un triptyque ce triptyque c'est
protégez réguler sanctionné donc protégé
c'est toutes les actions de
sensibilisation qui font mener et
d'éducation également dès le plus jeune
âge
réguler c'est s'assurer que les
plateformes met en oeuvre tous les
moyens nécessaires pour en effet assurer
la protection de leurs utilisateurs
et c'est pas leur demander de se
substituer au juge mais de mieux
appliquer des lois qui sont des oies
ancien qui date de 20 ans qui leur donne
un pouvoir de modération mais qu'il n'en
dit pas comment le faire et c'est ça
qu'on va imposer par la loi française et
la loi européenne puisqu'il ya un projet
de règlement sur la table il sanctionné
c'est la lutte contre l'impunité
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui poster des
messages haineux injurieux qui porte
atteinte à la dignité humaine et se dire
qu'on a mais une chance infinitésimale
de se retrouver devant le juge cela doit
changer en 2018 ou 2019
on a eu un peu plus de 200 condamnations
pour injure raciste en ligne toute la
france ce n'est rien ce n'est absolument
rien le problème c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de plaintes les enquêtes ne prospère pas
et puis comme les encadrent les enquêtes
ne prospère pas eh bien les gens n'y a
pas de sanctions et les gens ne dépose
pas plainte donc on est dans un cercle
vicieux c'est ça qu'il faut changer pour
cela aussi il faut que les plateformes
coopèrent davantage
c'est vrai qu'on en parle vous avez une
oreille bien le parquet numérique c'est
de pouvoir récupérer les éléments
d'identification des utilisateurs et
c'est ça aussi l'élément qui permet de
changer la donne et je voudrais qu'on
parle effectivement de ses plateformes
et de leur potentiel responsabilités
vous avez dit qu'elle ne voulait
fondamentalement pas faire de mal et on
imagine bien alors il ya certaines comme
facebook essaie de montrer patte blanche
mais globalement le buzz qu'il soit bon
ou mauvais c'est leur fond de commerce
je voudrais qu'on écoute le président du
groupe les indépendances sénat c'est
claude malhuret et il formule et les
choses ainsi en novembre dernier c'est
lors d'un débat sur le sujet au sénat et
coûter
il est urgent de se donner les lois
enfin efficace contre la haine en ligne
les chaînes sera pas facile en raison de
l'obstruction des plateformes qui lutte
pied à pied contre les régulations parce
que c'est leur business model même qui
est en cause
voici ce que dit le twitter tristane
harris ancien ingénieur de google
auditionné par la commission bancaire du
sénat américain pour chaque mot
d'indignation ajouté à un tweet le taux
de retweets augmentent en moyenne de 17%
en d'autres termes la polarisation de
notre société fait partie du modèle
commercial des réseaux sociaux
fin de citation serge abitbol oui oui
bien sûr mais mais mais c'est ça c'est
un il faut regarder dans nos salles dans
toute sa complexité dehors tout tous les
réseaux sociaux n'ont pas la même
attitude et facebook dont vous avez
parlé fait énormément d'efforts
d'investissement c'est mesurables pour
essayer de régler le problème
d'autres font rien du tout on pas parler
de twitter mais des choses comme vk en
russie vous pouvez faire à peu près tous
publiez ce que vous voulez donc c'est il
faut il faut regarder un peu ça et
surtout la question c'est comment on va
arriver à régler le problème
et encore une fois on peut on peut
mettre beaucoup de juges beaucoup de
policiers ça va être compliqué devant
les milliard de contenus qui arrivent
tous les jours mais demande aux
populations de jouer le jeu ça voilà des
policiers la question c'est exactement
ça c'est avoir un dialogue constructif
avec les plateformes avec un régulateur
extrêmement fort et un régulateur aux
pairs européens refusent évidemment plus
de poids un régulateur fort qui peut
négocier avec les plateformes qui ait
une transparence totale qui n'obtiennent
possibilités d'investigation énorme et
qui peut aller regarder par tous dans la
plateforme
et puis qui après mais des objectifs
donc on parle beaucoup avec le ds ac qui
le lot directive services aux actes est
total et madame avia de la loi
européenne parle beaucoup d'obligations
de moyen c'est à dire que on va vérifier
que ces entreprises mettent vraiment le
moyen de régler le problème et on va
discuter avec elle on va leur poser des
objectifs
et puis après comme comme bien dit tout
à fait madame avia 1,6 à font pas le
boulot dans ces cas là
il ya des sanctions et les south
sanction doit être à la meuse doivent
être à la mesure des dégâts qui sont
cause mais ce ya quand même un problème
structurel un problème de fond je suis
désolé encore une fois c'est leur font
commerce le buzz et qu'il soit bon ou
mauvais et plutôt d'ailleurs s'il est
mauvais c'est ce qui les fait marcher je
vous ai paix de martinon alors il est
difficile de d'avoir une seule réponse
en tant que modèle économique de ses
différentes plateformes entre un moteur
de recherche un réseau social
l'exemple de twitter twitter fonctionne
sur un principe des changes où
évidemment assez rapidement des éclats
peuvent peuvent arriver et d opposition
frontale entre l'autre les utilisateurs
twitter et d'ailleurs n'est pas dans le
dans l'acronyme de gars femmes et est
une petite structure qui n'a pas
forcément les moyens d'autres je ne suis
pas là pour pour la défendre mais en
tout cas je pense aujourd'hui qu'il ya
sans doute un nécessité d'une plus
grande
une plus grande capacité à échanger à
ouvrir son mode de fonctionnement
on oublie de mentionner parce que c'est
très bien de parler du dsa de l'europe
et qui est de tout ce qu'on peut faire
même en france n'oublions pas que le
réseau internet les échanges en ligne se
font au niveau mondial et que la
nécessité c'est la coopération mondiale
vous mentionnez les acteurs russes
moldaves ou chinois dit demain un
meilleur travail est effectué dans les
échanges entre régulateurs et
plateformes européennes ou plates formes
américaines ayant pignon sur rue en
europe
ray il n'y aura toujours ce problème
récurrent de d'acteurs étrangers or on
va dire monde occidental classique qui
permettront de père prêté ces abus et il
n'y a pas aujourd'hui de signaux forts
de coopération internationale il n'y a
pas de revenus du numérique mais il en
faudrait sans doute en tous les cas on
ne peut pas s'amuser à balayer devant sa
porte
quand la tempête et est à côté et on
court le risque de voir toujours plus de
trafic toujours plus de buzz pour
reprendre votre terme sur d'autres
structures qui ne se situe pas dans
notre territoire européen et donc qui
pourrait aller encore plus loin dans le
non respect de principes de base est une
idée ça serge abiteboul à un inconnu du
du numérique
c'est sûr que les problèmes et en étant
mondiaux il y aura besoin d'arriver à
des à des décisions mondiales mais moi
je crois quand même beaucoup que ce
niveau européen je crois assez peu qu'on
arrivera à moyen terme à faire converger
des pays qui veulent pas du tout ça fait
s'aligner sur nos valeurs
par contre je crois vraiment qu en
europe on a comme on l'a fait avec la
rgpp avec plus ou moins de succès mais
qu'on a quand même réussi on peut
arriver à dallas à voir tous les mêmes
valeurs non plus au sein des vingt-sept
dialogue on arrive et puis sur le débat
il ya des bonnes engueulades on va dire
mais bon mais on peut avancer
et puis on peut arriver à avoir quelque
chose de plus efficace alors après pour
pour revenir à votre question par
exemple sur v cas c'est à dire que soit
ils joueront le jeu soit on l'est on les
fermoirs fasse ses environs les bloquera
on bloquera leur est alors c'est
quantifier repartiront jour même sur
d'autres
avec d'autres adresses c'est un jeu de
chasse aux chats compliqué mais chan
souris mais on peut pas juste accepter
que je sais bien su a dit autour de la
table que ça ne peut pas être un lieu de
non droit donc soit ils appliqueront le
droit soit ils se font sortir du jeu
quoi laetitia via sur le volet mondiale
il volait peut-être européens d'abord
avant de parler d'un an est venue du
numérique mais au niveau européen on a
beaucoup parlé des efforts des des
plateformes
je travaille depuis trois ans de manière
très étroite avec les plateformes et ce
que j'entends c'est beaucoup de belles
intentions et lorsqu'il s'agit de mettre
les choses en oeuvre de mettre des
moyens et notamment des moyens humains
ou des moyens financiers et plus grand
monde
lorsqu'on essaye de légiférer à
l'échelle nationale on nous renvoie vers
l'échelle européenne lorsqu'on est à
l'échelle européenne on nous renvoie
vers l'échelle mondiale je crois en
réalité que les plateformes à veulent
décider elles veulent décider de ce qui
s'applique à me décider de la manière d
appliquer quand comment pourquoi
et tout cela en raison d'enjeux
financiers on l'a dit les propos haineux
ses propois à charge émotionnelle sont
ceux qui qui vraiment engrange le plus
de contenu aujourd'hui les enjeux
financiers sont autres puisqu'il ya la
question de la régulation des sanctions
pour imposer aussi bien à l'échelle
nationale qu'à l'échelle européenne
et puis aussi le jeu des annonceurs les
annonceurs qui ne veulent plus être liée
à des plates formes qui sont des lieux
de propagation de la haine et qui donc
eux aussi font bouger les choses et je
prends en effet que c'est uniquement les
enjeux économiques qui permettront de
faire bouger les choses
à quelque échelle que ce soit oui c'est
un levier intéressant ça vous pensez que
ce en appuyant sur ce levier on pourrait
finalement faire bouger les lignes du
côté des plateformes et on l'a vu on a
vu dès lors qu'un certain nombre
d'acteurs économiques que ce soit donc
les annonceurs publicitaires ou ou des
grands comptes ont commencé à quitter
les réseaux sociaux je m'étais a ému
d'une publication du responsable de
facebook france qui nous indiquaient
qu'ils allaient créer de nouveaux
filtres de modération sur instagram à la
suite des points d'alert qu'ils ont reçu
de la part d
sportif de haut niveau donc c'est vrai
que dès que thierry henry qui te quitte
instagram on se dit ah attention ce
poème des grands comptes là il faut
qu'on agisse et toutes les personnes qui
sont victimes de la haine en ligne
depuis des années toutes les
associations qui se mobilisent depuis
des années l on n entendait pas eh bien
oui c'est les enjeux économiques qui
font bouger le plateforme
donc on va utiliser également ces enjeux
là pour les faire bouger ses rivales a
donc c'est pas le droit c'est pas les
contraintes juridiques c'est plutôt du
coût des contraintes économiques qui
pourraient jouer notamment notamment la
loi la loi allemande contrôleur
scellement ligne a montré également que
les des amendes ou et très extrêmement
efficace contre les contres les
plateformes dont le droit ne peut pas
tout faire vous pouvez bien organisés au
niveau mondial toutes les la plus belle
organisation que kiki soit ça
n'empêchera pas quelques abrutis
oui malheureusement trop nombreux
d'envoyer d'envoyer des messages
comment les combattons et il faut les
éduquer ces gens là il faut leur
apprendre que ce n'est pas ça ne se fait
pas que c'est que c'est mal et que ça
peut être qu'ils s'apaisent fonctionner
donc là on en revient on ne revient à la
pédagogie et je crois que c'est très
important notamment la faveur de deux
procès ils sont quasiment aujourd'hui
quotidien on avait chaque semaine une
panne ou à nouveau un nouveau procès des
faux pour harcèlement il faut il faut
marteler que il y à il ya véritablement
c'est impératif on doit on doit rester
correct alors et que ça peut et que ça
peut quand même être être être
sanctionner gravement trop rarement bien
sûr mais je rappelle que pour la
première fois en france au mois
d'octobre 2020 dans le froid c'est
marvel fitness il y a eu une peine de
prison ferme pour harcèlement
harcèlement en ligne
c'était un youtube heures qui avait
appelé sa communauté a harcelé de
manière extrêmement virulente et est
scandaleuse
une de ses concurrentes et il a été
condamné à deux ans deux ans avec sursis
est qu est un enfer bon là c'est ça ça
fait réfléchir il a fait appel bien sûr
on verra ce qu'il en est devant la cour
mais néanmoins ça montre que ce n'est
pas anodin qui a qui a véritablement
derrière une potentielle sanctions et
pas uniquement un stage de citoyenneté à
faire sur deux jours parce qu'on a
beaucoup parlé
des mesures a posteriori mais vous avez
raison parlons aussi de ce sur quoi on
vend ce à quoi on peut s'attaquer à
priori c'est à dire effectivement
pédagogie éducation prévention c'est
aussi la demande des sénateurs et
notamment des rigoles du rassemblement
démocratique social et européen je
voudrais qu'on écoute mais aucune loi
n'empêchera jamais ces discussions de
comptoir sur internet qui peuvent mener
à la violence sans le filtre de la
conversation et du débat éclairé seule
l'éducation en limitera les fm c'est
pourquoi l'investissement de l'état dans
la lutte contre l'électronique mme
pourrait être l'occasion de renforcer la
sensibilisation des plus jeunes à ces
sujets conformément aux recommandations
de la mission d'information de notre
groupe sur l'électro nisme giuseppe de
martino
seule l'éducation limitera les effets
donc le rôle des parents est essentielle
mais aurait également le dossier qui ne
connaissent rien
complètement donc des mesures
pédagogiques doivent être faits au
niveau de l'enseignement est ce qu'on
apprend aujourd'hui à comment se servir
d'internet quels sont les dangers les
parents accompagnent leurs enfants la
première fois où ils vont faire des
courses tout seul on leur apprend à
traverser à regarder à droite et à
gauche donnait son argent récupéré la
monnaie pourquoi on ne tente pas la même
chose côté parents parce qu'il apporte
aussi quelques chose pardonnez moi je
suis aussi en tant que parent moi-même
et quelque chose d'un peu intrusif
d'aller dans le téléphone portable ou de
lui expliquer comment fait on
l'enfance est aussi son bien
las dos et son univers c'est sont
d'ailleurs à lui mais il faut rappeler
ces quelques règles
le jour où on donne la première fois le
téléphone il faut toujours avoir ce
dialogue avec les enfants sur les bons
usages et les mauvaises usages des
technologies et surtout encore une fois
rendre public
new media parler de ces condamnations de
la delà de l'absence d' impunité en
ligne quand elle est réelle oui et et à
l'école et les profs les profs ont
beaucoup de choses à faire on a tous
dans notre industrie du numérique pas se
donner du temps pour se rendre dans les
écoles pour expliquer on sent que ce
soutien est important sans doute pas
suffisant et avec ce ce mammouth de
l'éducation française sans doute j'ai
encore beaucoup de chantiers affaires et
celui ci n'est pas forcément prioritaire
alors qu'ils le devraient être un peu
court il est peut-être un prioritaire
laetitia via maintenant tu as fait
d'autant plus que nous avons à
l'assemblée nationale votait la
généralisation du permis internet alors
de quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit d'une formation qui aurait
lieu à la fin de l'école primaire et une
seconde fois à la fin du collège
pour sensibiliser enfants gays aux
usages du numérique au risque du
numérique aux dérives à l'économie de
l'attention d'enfermement algorithmique
tout cela mieux comprendre ces outils
mieux comprendre ses usages et
développer un usage
citoyen en fait aussi du numérique
malheureusement cette disposition a été
retirée du texte par le sénat
lorsque le texte est arrivé donc au
sénat dans quelques projets de lois
principes républicains
donc la semaine prochaine à l'assemblée
je vais représenter ces dispositions
j'espère qu'elle fera consensus parce
que s'il faut agir en matière
d'éducation tout cas d'éducation
nationale c'est ainsi je pense qu'on
peut le faire
serge abitbol je partage mais alors
complètement cessé les deux derniers
points de vues sur la nécessité de
l'éducation circa à court terme on peut
faire des lois on peut faire de la
régulation peut punir mais à long terme
il faut que les enfants et la population
apprennent à se comporter à la fois
comme consommateurs sur ces réseaux mais
aussi comme producteur sert savoir
comment le produire comment écrire sur
ces réseaux et je rajouterais une
composante aussi c'est que pour moi ça
ne peut pas être dissociée aussi d'un
enseignement de l'informatique et des
outils c'est à dire de d'une
compréhension de qu'est ce qui se passe
là dedans tu penses que par exemple
comprendre ce que fait un algorithme de
recommandation c'est assez assez
essentielle pour que pour pouvoir mieux
les utiliser mieux mieux savoir ce
qu'ils visualisent est un peu ce qui se
passe bien sur les skis se passe est en
fait c'est compliqué parce que le
d'alcool de recommandation chez facebook
n'est pas le même que c'est sur le fil
twitter qui est pas le même que chez
google search
donc c'est les choses qu'il faut
comprendre pour comprendre comment
comment fonctionne comment ça fonctionne
comment sait manipuler un bouc run vous
comprenez mieux comment vous fait
manipuler si vous comprenez qu'elle et
l'algorithme derrière mais alors très
concrètement si vous en aviez le pouvoir
qu est-ce que vous organiserez y ait
dans les écoles un cours hebdomadaire
sur les médias sociaux en général
comment s'en servir ou qu'est-ce qu'il
faut les introduire dans le programme
scolaire
alors tout d'abord ça peut se faire à
l'intérieur de l'enseignement de
l'informatique qui étaient installés à
l'école et dans laquelle on peut
rajouter ses dimensions même s'il ya
déjà la barque est déjà assez lourde
et puis tous cas cacité madame avia sur
le fait que les élèves doivent apprendre
et je pense que alors je connais pas le
détail de la loi mais le
le prix la fin du primaire et la fin du
collège me paraissent était bon moment
pour familiariser les les jeunes avec
ses dimensions là et ses dimensions qui
vont qu'ils vont côtoyer toute leur vie
et donc il faut c'est important qu'il
laisse apprennent vite
thierry voilà moi moi l'éducation je je
je je prône cette c'est cette valeur
depuis depuis toujours je pense que
c'est par là que qu'il faut commencer et
puis aussi un autre pour lutter contre
la haine en ligne je crois que ne pas ne
pas victimiser ne pas accuser encore
plus ces victimes qu'elles ne le sont et
qu'ils se sentent déjà extrêmement
fragile par rapport à leur situation et
je crois qu'il faut les aider il faut
faire comprendre aux gens qui sont
harcelés que ce n'est pas de leur faute
et qu'il faut aller porter plainte qu'il
faut voilà donc c'est aussi une écoute
de plus en plus importante de la part
des officiers de police judiciaire qui
vont avoir à recueillir la plainte des
magistrats qui vont avoir recueillir
leur parole et faire comprendre que
voilà ce qu elles subissent le préjudice
qu'elles ont que quelques et qu'elles
subissent et est véritablement pas de
pas de leur fait et donc celle
pédagogique également des magistrats
également sur le volet judiciaire est
très important il a il a commencé à être
fait et aujourd'hui on a beaucoup avancé
il n'est pas encore parfait et je pense
que ça cette pédagogie est aussi valable
du côté judiciaire
oui vous pointez quelque chose
d'intéressant de ses rivales à parce que
cette formation à l'écouté des policiers
des gendarmes des magistrats on en parle
par exemple pour les violences faites
aux femmes on s'aperçoit que ça a été
compliqué d'entendre les femmes qui
avaient été victimes de violences
vous pensez que c'est aussi compliqué
pour les victimes de cyber harcèlement
d'être entendus ils sont pas formés
combat à oui mais bon quand elle a
commencé à les porter plainte pour pour
ce type de ce type de délit on nous
regardait avec des grands yeux mais
qu'est ce que c'est c'est pas vraiment
quelque chose ça va être
voilà mes fait une main courante mais
voilà c'est pas là c'est pas une plainte
à voilà que que n'at-on pas entendu
c'est exactement la même chose
donc petit à petit on ça ça ça rentre
dans les moeurs la création du parc
national
numérique est une bonne chose et
heureusement dans cette loi qui était
fort contestée qui a été rabroué par le
conseil constitutionnel parce qu elle
était vraiment intéressante et pratique
maintenant
maintenant il faut il ya encore beaucoup
de progrès à faire mais les magistrats
maintenant comprennent que ces maps etc
au sirop sur internet que ça n'existe
pas que c'est virtuel un dommage fait
sur internet est un vrai dommage dans la
vraie vie et sarah ça doit être martelé
et que les gens qui sont victimes
doivent pouvoir porter plainte de
manière très sereine et ne pas être en
plus être va la considérer comme étant
les participants à leur propre leur
propre désarroi
c'est là aussi un levier laetitia via et
peut-être pour conclure ce débat il faut
aussi à les former à l'ecoute gendarmes
policiers et magistrats
oui bien sûr alors c'est vrai que ça
prend du temps et c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on a lancée très rapidement ce parc
et numérique
aujourd'hui quand vous allez déposer
plainte un sujet de liberté d'expression
et en plus numérique
on sent une certaine frilosité et c'est
ça qui fait aussi que que les victimes
sont sont seuls donc il ya une vraie
formation à faire deux à la fois nos
policiers dans les registres à une
acculturation en fait passer à ses
délits est d'ores et déjà se parquer
numérique qui prend le relais qui
absorbe les affaires sensibles
les affaires massive de cyber
harcèlement quand on a dix mille
messages on va parler avec 10000
captures d'écran et donc il faut avoir
des personnes qui savent gérer ce pas et
bientôt on aura aussi la possibilité de
déposer plainte en ligne n'est pas juste
une pré plainte mais le plein en entier
lorsqu'on est victime de haine en ligne
et là aussi je pense que ça incitera les
victimes à agen valoir leurs droits et
on s'arrêtera sur ces pistes d'avenir
merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé aux grands débats de lpl c'est
la fin de cette émission on se retrouve
lundi
18 heures et à 22 heures pour un nouveau
numéro et puis demain matin dès 7h30
bonjour chez vous au rayonnement de
chimie recevra guillaume larrivé députés
aient l'air de l'yonne je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée sur public sénat
[Musique]